greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
with simply learn and welcome to today's
webinar today we're gonna talk about
digital marketing tools so fasten your
seat belts and let's get started
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
take a look at some of the best digital
marketing tools for not only 2019 the
ones that are performed well in the past
that are popular and ones that we
foresee as being the go-to tools for the
future
so past present and future digital
marketing tools is the way to look at
this with a good focus on a lot of
different marketing channels here so
we're gonna focus first on SEO talk
about some of the tools related to
on-page and off-page we're going to
switch over to paid search like a little
bit about paid search tools we're going
to talk about email marketing and some
of the email marketing platforms and the
tools within those platforms the center
of it all is web analytics so Google
Analytics is the tool we'll be taking a
closer look at in today's webinar and
all that it has to offer
affiliate marketing we'll talk about
some of the tools available to you and
for affiliate marketing we'd be remiss
if we didn't talk about social media all
that it has to offer and all the metrics
and tools available all the platforms
available so we'll hone in on a couple
of examples there and then we'll also
talk about some competition tools
available for you so there's a whole
suite of tools the one caveat being hey
if you have your favorite tool continue
using it in fact if there's a tool that
we didn't mention in today's webinar
feel free to mention it in the comment
box below this video we'd love to hear
what you're using to manage your
particular digital marketing channel
okay and so the goal for today's webinar
is hey we hope you get something out of
this in terms of using new tools there's
some tools that I use some tools that my
colleagues use everybody uses different
tools so it'd be good to kind of see
what else is out there so if you have
something to share share it by all means
what we're trying to do is share what we
think are you know best practices and
some of the most popular or most used
tools out there in the industry so
that's what we're going to do the goal
is to get you to better understand some
of the tools we're using a little bit
more detail and what we're gonna do is
start out with search engine
optimization okay so search engine
amount optimization or organic search we
have a mixture of paid and free so
there's a lot of different platforms but
if you're focusing on SEO you certainly
need to use an SEO platform so there's
SEM rush okay you also have Google
search console which is free so if you
don't have a SEO platform you definitely
need to be using Google search console
and so we'll take a closer look at that
there's Google Keyword planner which is
actually situated under Google Ads and
so if you're running Google campaigns on
Google search Network or even the
Display Network you have access to a
great tool called keyword planner and if
you know anything about SEO you'll know
that using Google's keyword planner is a
good tool so we'll take a look at that
Moz is a freemium tool meaning they have
a free trial that you can sign up for to
test drive it but it's another SEO
platform and it does cost money got a
great tool and screaming frog that's a
paid version again not too expensive
we'll talk a little bit more about that
and then we have you know a tool and a
traps that help us with all aspects of
SEO primarily focusing on off page so
these are just some examples that we're
gonna hone in on but this is just a
small subset of what really is available
out there in the market so let's go
ahead and dive a little bit deeper and
understand why we use some of these
tools well the first reason when we talk
about SEO is to find relevant keywords
not only do we want to find relevant
keywords we want to find relevant
keywords with high volume
competition okay we wouldn't want to
find non relevant keywords with high
competition low volume that wouldn't
make sense so we need a tool to kind of
help us put it all together and so the
tool of choice for us is Google's
keyword planner and Google's keyword
planner helps us hone in on keywords we
may be interested and optimizing for
because not only one are they relevant
but two they're going to have high
volume and low competition so let's take
a look at an example in Google's keyword
planner so here I am I'm in Google's
keyword planner and as I mentioned
before Google's keyword planner is
situated under Google Ads okay so you
have to have a Google Ads
account to use Google's keyword planner
and so when you're in Google Ads you
simply go to tools and then under tools
you're gonna select keyword planner so
what we want to do is look for keywords
we're focusing on organic search not
necessarily paid search so organic
search we want to hone in on some
keywords so what you see is one of the
examples that Google's giving us here
meal delivery so we're gonna just type
in mail delivery and get some results so
notice I can enter a domain as a filter
and so in other words hey I could say
look hone in on keywords related to this
website if I wanted to but I'm asking
Google hey just give me something
closely related to mail delivery because
that's my business so I'm gonna click
click get results notice I can add
another key to it if I wanted to but I'm
just gonna stick with one keyword but
there are certainly other keywords that
I can certainly hone in on if mail
delivery is my business and so let's
just hone in on that one keyword mail
delivery we want to be found organically
for that keyword so what Google Keyword
planner does is not only give us the key
word in other keywords relevant to that
but it gives us the average monthly
search volumes and this is an average
over the course of the last 12 months
and notice here I get a column for
competition
so I'm able to see whether that's a very
competitive keyword or not and then just
to give you an extra edge when you're
choosing keywords you can get a sense of
what the keyword may cost if you want it
to bid on that for paid search so for
mail delivery I can see it's anywhere
between seven dollars and forty six
cents and at the top of the page high
range $16.60 so that should alert me to
the fact that hey if I'm gonna try and
optimize for this keyword I know it's
competitive because not only Google is
telling me it's competitive by telling
me high competition but I know that the
cost per click seems a little bit high
and what is a little bit high well you
know I can see some other keywords here
that you know $1 to $3 okay I can see
some other ones that are even lower than
the $7 they're suggesting so that's an
indication that the keyword is highly
competitive so the idea here using
Google's keyword planner is one we want
to get an idea of what other keywords
are out there that are relevant so it
helps stimulate some ideas for relevancy
too we can get an average monthly search
volume so we want to know on average
over the past 12 months how many search
queries I can expect from this keyword
and then 3 I can get a sense of the
competition how competitive is this
keyword so if I try to optimize for this
keyword and I want to rank for it
organically is it competitive if it's
competitive then it's probably gonna
take me a bit longer to be found for
this keyword on page 1 of Google so
that's the whole idea behind Google's
keyword planner and note that you could
change some of the settings here so if
you want to choose a different language
okay you can hone in on a longer or
shorter period of time you can even
choose a specific location so I chose
Texas I can certainly choose the entire
United States to get a sense of what the
volume would be for the total US so you
have settings that you can change
and manipulate to get you the data you
need to choose keywords so that's the
whole idea behind Google's keyword
planner to find relevant keywords high
volume low competition now alternatively
I can certainly use another tool to find
keywords so I have a mods account so I
logged in to Moz and Moz has a tool
called keyword Explorer so if I use that
same keyword I used in Google's keyword
planner mail delivery I'm gonna ask mods
to give me some data on that keyword so
this is for the entire United States and
again I can change that if I wanted to
okay so I can hone in on a specific
country or different country
so what Moz is tell me hey for this
keyword in the entire United States I'm
looking at anywhere from eleven and a
half thousand to thirty thousand on
monthly volume
now what Moz does is they give you a
difficulty score so a difficulty score
is a score between 1 and 100 and so I
can see this is pretty much right down
the middle in terms of difficulty okay
so if it's 0 it's an easy keyword if
it's not if it's a hundred it's very
difficult and then that means you have a
lot of competitors who are optimizing
for this keyword that are ranking for
this keyword and so Moz gives us the
volume they give us the competition and
they just like Google's keyword planner
gives us some other keywords that we can
potentially hone in on so here I could
see keyword delivery plans delivery
services etc so I can see a lot more
suggestions than what's listed here so
Moz delivers a bunch of other analysis
related to the keyword you know they
also give you some good keyword
suggestions so Moz is a good alternative
tool and we'll be coming back to Moz
related to SEO for some other of its
features but for now if you don't want
to necessarily use Google's keyword
planner because maybe you're not running
Google Ads you can always use Mazda
remember Moz has basically a freemium
version meaning you can sign up for a
free account
and you can sign up for a free account
as a test trial and you could test it
for a period of days and leverage its
tools during that free trial to get a
better sense of how these tools work so
we want to be able to use mods we want
to be able to use Google's keyword
planner not only to search for all those
relevant keywords available to you but
we want to be able to choose keywords
with high volume and low difficulty low
competition we also want to select
primary and second key words wisely so
remember when you optimize you're
optimizing a page for more than one
keyword so you want to be able to have a
nice portfolio of diverse relevant
keywords with high search volume and low
difficulty and then you want to be able
to identify those keywords that your
competitors are ranking for so Moz gives
you that information and so we want to
be able to leverage the tools available
to us to choose the right keywords so if
you need any more information on this we
got a nice webinar on keyword research
for SEO so take a look at that
video on YouTube and to get more
specific details about using SEO tools
for keyword research and all about
keyword research in general for SEO so
let's talk about some other reasons
under SEO why we would use some of these
tools available to us well we want to be
able to understand the search engines
and how they crawl and index our site
okay we also want to check the correct
format of the sitemap and we want to
monitor backlinks okay we also want to
analyze linking to our web page okay
which ones are good which ones are not
good okay we also want to perform some
competitor analysis so these are some of
the reasons why other than keyword
research why would we use some of these
SEO tools so we have tools available to
us some Majestic h refs again Moz let's
take a look at google search console and
I want to hone in on Google search
console because it is free and it's a
must if you're gonna work on SEO you
need to be working in Google search
console and so the whole key behind
Google search console is you have a
website and you need to get that site
verified once it's verified one school
can recognize that you are associated
with this website then you're going to
be able to see some important
information so here I'm looking at a
website and what am I looking at I'm
looking at something called coverage
under index so what does coverage mean
well going back to what we just said we
want to be able to understand how
Google's crawling and indexing our pages
and so what Google does is through this
platform search console is there letting
us know once they go to our website and
start crawling it and they pull these
pages back to their server they're
letting us know if we actually have any
issues so here I can see I have some
issues with 112 pages and some of those
issues are listed down here so there
could be a crawl issue a for for you
know redirect okay so you could see
there's some five unique issues across
112 pages so here I can see submitted
URL marked new index there's a hundred
of those pages we have some redirect
errors there seven pages that you know
fall victim to this error and so we can
really hone in what the ear is and
address the ear okay so if Google is
telling us hey this is an issue and you
want that page indexed by Google then we
should probably address the error and so
that's the great thing here about going
into Google search console is you can
under index go to coverage and get a
sense of what Google's indexing and what
they're not indexing so these are the
errors I can see they've certainly were
able to crawl and index 9,000 115 pages
they were able to crawl okay and they
excluded 54,000 plus pages and then we
also have some pages with some warnings
so this is kind of an overview of what
Google sees when they crawl
our site so when they say crawl they're
coming to our site they're following
links on the site and every link they
follow they're either going to index
that page or they're going to report to
you an error or an issue that they found
if we want these pages indexed we need
to address the issues the errors and so
that's the beauty of this report here as
Google is telling us firsthand what the
issues are so we also want to take a
look at the site map so you have an
opportunity to submit a site map but a
site map is just a formatted file that
includes all your website URLs and so
you're going to have this file sitting
in your root directory and you're
probably going to call it or should call
it sitemap XML XML being the format so
once you have this file you're just
gonna let Google know that that file
exists so you're gonna enter in the
sitemap URL so if it's in the root
directory all you're gonna do is type in
sitemap XML and click Submit so once
you've done it just like this site is
done what Google's gonna do is say hey
look we see you've submitted this and we
last read it a couple days ago and we
could see that we discovered 1419 URLs
so I can go back under coverage and I
can see some of the issues that they've
found but if I go back under sitemaps I
can see that these are the URLs they've
discovered via the sitemap and so the
whole point of a sitemap is we want to
be able to get and push the URLs to
Google not have Google come to our site
and discover them so this is a quicker
faster more efficient way to communicate
with Google all the URLs that you have
on your site that you want Google to
index and so that's the beauty of search
console now while we're in search
console we might as well take a look at
some of the other features it has and so
one of the most important features under
search console is this mobile usability
report ok so Google is a staunch
believer in mobile first so nowadays
most people start and finish a lot of
searches a lot of their behavior on
mobile so the beginning on mobile and
they may end it on mobile so if they
don't end it on mobile then you know
perhaps they'll go into a store or
perhaps they'll go via desktop but
Google is a staunch believer and
definitely a lot of what's going on
today starts with mobile so they want
you to understand how your site fares
via mobile
and when I say fares via mobile is it
mobile-friendly isn't responsive is it
loading quick enough you know is it
formatted to Google standards and so if
there are any issues Google's gonna let
you know what those issues are so here I
could see Google's recognized two
hundred and six pages before different
issues okay so here I can see what those
issues are just like the coverage issues
we can see specifically what they are
and so here I can see for 206 pages text
too small to read click elements too
close together the viewport not set to
device width and then content wider than
the screen so there's ten pages that fit
under this air and if I actually click
on it the air I can see what those 10
pages are and so when we're done we can
actually when we address the issues we
can actually have Google validate
whether the fix has been made so you can
definitely use this as a means of
communicating directly with Google
telling Google look I see what the
issues are I'm gonna fix them and then I
want you to validate them ok so this is
important because if you can communicate
with Google and let them know hey we do
recognize the errors we are fixing the
errors please validate them you know
it's going to draw Google's attention
Google's going to validate them and get
these pages indexed quicker so if you
ignore the issues than the errors
especially for mobile then you stand the
chance of your pages not getting indexed
so the mobile usability report to me is
an important report because we want to
better understand whether Google's
picking up issues on mobile and if they
are we want to address them get a little
valley them so Google can
next and quicker now there's another
report that is of interest to you or may
be of interest to you in Google search
console and that's the Lynx report
so the Lynx report in Google search
console shows us what pages have the
most links okay so here we can see the
home page is 26,000 plus links we hone
in on interior pages we can see the
links to those pages ok so we can get a
sense of one of the topped link pages
from external links meaning links on
other websites pointing to these pages I
can also see internal links so Google is
recognizing links from within my website
from one page to another so external
links internal links both factors for
SEO when ranking so then I can see top
linking sites what sites are linking to
my site and then I can see top linking
text so Google search console has given
me kind of an overview of what my
leaking structure looks like
okay so externally I want links from
other websites pointing to various pages
on my site and I certainly want my page
is linking to one another on my site and
so I'd be able to better understand what
that structure looks like using Google
search consoles links report ok there's
one more report that I thinks of
interest in Google search console and
that's the performance report so the
performance report is a report that
actually you can link up with Google
Analytics so you could see the same
report and analytics if you're able to
link up Google search console with
analytics and you should be able to do
that all you need to do is make sure you
use the same email address that you use
for analytics in search console so it
needs to be the same email address you
could certainly link up the two and have
this data imported into Google Analytics
so what is this data that we're talking
about
well it's called performance so what we
can actually see is the queries the
actual queries people are typing in to
Google so when they're typing them into
Google we can actually see how many
impressions the keyword
queries received and how many clicks the
Queen Word queries received and then I
can see click-through rate an average
position okay so here I can see for this
particular keyword on the first line I
could see over the course of the last
three months
it received two hundred nine thousand
two hundred ninety seven impression so
what does that mean that means this
keyword was used at leat or typed in as
a query at least that many times and
that's how many times my listing
appeared and the Google search results
pages based on this particular query and
so as a result of somebody typing in
this query two hundred nine thousand
plus times this site received one
hundred twenty thousand plus clicks so
to get a sense of the click-through rate
all you would need to do and Google can
nicely do this for you is you would
simply just divide the two hundred nine
thousand 297 into the 120 thousand three
ninety seven okay so that's really gonna
give you that's going to give you a
click-through rate and the click-through
rate in this case is fifty seven percent
so over half of the clicks occur when
this listing appears for this keyword
okay so we can get a sense of the
click-through rate for each one okay and
you could simply just use the filtering
here now we can also see average
position okay so we could see a little
bit more than that too we can go from
queries to pages we can go from pages to
countries so we get a sense of how many
impressions and clicks I'm receiving by
country and importantly we can see by
device so there I can see a majority of
the people who conduct a search related
to my website primarily do it on desktop
now I mentioned the beauty of the Google
search console performance report is
that you can link it up to Google
Analytics and when you do that all you
need to do then is go to acquisition
Google search console and then from
there you could choose landing pages
countries devices or queries so I can
see the same data that I see in search
console but this time
looking at it in Google Analytics and so
here I can see when my search queries
are my clicks my impressions my clicked
array bike search query and then the
average position so that's the great
thing about that performance report is
that when I link up Google search
console with analytics I'm able to see
that data in analytics so that's an
added bonus so to speak now let's talk
about some other reasons why we are
going to use these SEO tools available
to us and so we already listed a number
of different reasons ranging from
sitemaps to keyword research but we also
want to hone in on you know what domains
are driving links to our site so I
showed you an example in search console
we also want to hey may be identifying
disavowed poor backlinks so search
console is a great tool for that because
if we don't want to be in Sochi ated
with a particular website we can
certainly disavow that link we could
track a number of follow and no follow
links okay we could track our website's
rankings we can measure click-through
rates and impressions just as we did
with search console we could track
keyword ranking for desktop mobile
across locations just as we just did
with the search console performance
report we can identify top performing
gaining and losing keywords again the
performance report so we could certainly
look at the Google search console report
but if you have a platform like Moz you
can certainly also look at a lot of that
data available so for example rankings
simply of a Moz account we can certainly
go into rankings okay and we can see for
the keywords that we've chosen that we
want to optimize for we can certainly
see where they rank the great thing
about Moz is it's a great tool not only
for rankings and on-page optimization
but for off page optimisation as well so
if I go ahead and take a look at a
domain for example I'm just gonna type
in this domain I'm gonna be able to get
what they call a domain Authority so a
score out of one and 100 I'm able
to see how authoritative my domain is
and how authoritative a domain is is
based on the quality of Link's pointing
to it so Maas gives me some good
insights as to how many linking domains
how many inbound links I have ranking
keywords and it goes into detail as well
so here if I click on the linking
domains I'm going to be actual able to
see the actual domains pointing to my
site as an external link and not only
can I see the domains I can actually see
the domain authority of those domains so
if there's a domain for example that
doesn't have a good domain Authority and
the site appears a bit scammy per se
then we can disavow that so I can
certainly look at all the domains that
are linking to me and that can highlight
the ones that have poor domain Authority
what Moz even takes it a step further
they also give me a spam score so Moz is
able to measure how spammy a website is
so if I have a combination of say a low
domain authority and a high spam score
then I probably want to disavow myself
from that site and so I can use this
report here you can see here as I keep
going down for example I can see this
particular website has a domain
Authority of 26 and it as a spam score
of 16 percent so not a good combination
this should alert me to the fact that
hey this particular site because it has
so many links pointing to me or it has
at least one link pointing to me that I
probably want to disavow myself because
it's probably hurting my own domain
Authority so that's the great thing
about this linking domains report is I'm
able to hone in on not only whose link
linking to me
meaning domain but how many linking
domains does that domain have what's the
spam score of that domain what's the
domain authority of that domain and then
I could get into a little bit more
detail and actually see you know all the
links pointing to that domain so it
really go
into detail about backlinks domain
authority spam etc everything you need
to use in order to measure off page SEO
so that's the great thing about Moz is
they have not only on-page SEO tools but
off page SEO tools and Moz is a freemium
so to speak so here you can see if you
just go to Moz com slash free - SEO -
tools you'll be able to use some of
these tools available to you not just
for SEO but also for local SEO as well
so here you like some of these tools you
can start your free 30-day trial so I
use and lean on Moz a lot for all that
it has to offer from choosing keywords
to rankings report to checking issues on
my website to even checking who's
linking to me so this fits in the MOL
with everything I need to do for SEO so
in addition to that keyword research
video you could certainly lean on some
other webinars that we've done in the
past on SEO so we've done a webinar on
SEO tools and we've also done a webinar
on SEO tips and tricks so if you want
any more information about the tools we
covered or SEO in general take a look at
those two videos and check them out and
that should kind of complement what we
talked about with using some of the
tools Google's keyword planner Moz and
Google search console okay let's switch
over to email marketing tools and so
with email marketing tools we have a lot
available to us in the form of reporting
in the form of platforms in the form of
you know tools that really help us go
from A to Z on our email choosing you
know what email to send out to creating
a list to measuring how the email
campaign went and so we could start with
MailChimp because MailChimp some
freemium version when we see freemium
meaning they have a free trial available
then you're expected to upgrade but you
know MailChimp to me is a tool I use
like the interface very easy for
beginners so we're gonna take a look at
MailChimp but there are certainly many
others available you know more cat is a
good tool you know more keto is a good
tool because if you have a business and
you're trying to funnel people through
your pipeline so to speak meaning they
say sign up as a lead and you want to
nurture that lead from the beginning to
the end meaning at the end they're
actually going to turn around and
purchase well Marketo is a good tool for
you to use because you can then start
rip campaigns or also known as email
campaigns you know so that you're
talking and communicating with that
particular prospect through every point
in the funnel so that's the great thing
about Marketo it has drip campaigns
available along with some other features
there's a hub spot as a require 'fl tool
it does a lot from creating landing
pages baby testing - social - you know
email so this is another freemium tool
that you could use you have another
freemium and send in blue email platform
and then you also have convertkit
another email platform yeah there's more
dimension that we can't even fit on this
screen now if you have a favorite email
marketing tool that you use Constant
Contact vertical response there plenty
out there Emma you know feel free to to
note that in the comments section below
this video I'm curious as to how many
people actually use you know different
tools because there are so literally so
many email marketing tools out there why
because email marketing has been around
probably the longest amongst all the
other digital marketing channels and a
lot of people who use email and I'm on a
daily basis so it's no wonder why
there's just so many tools available and
so with these tools you could certainly
send bulk emails now in the case of
Marketo you could send emails to a
segmented audience and so that's a
actually what you want to do as a
strategy's always send emails to a
segmented audience you know you want to
use a tool where you're going to be able
to create campaigns then send this
campaign
to again segmented context and then be
able to design your email around that
particular audience so you know you have
a good tool when you can do that when
you can really segment for your audience
now you want to be able to use a tool
that's going to be able to use segment
your users you know use transactional
emails meaning hey look if somebody
go-ahead went ahead and purchased can
you follow up with an email and creating
workflows just like I mentioned with
Marketo you want a workflow setup where
if somebody does this you're sending an
email B etc so you want an email
marketing tool that's flexible enough to
handle what your business strategy and
goals are okay so you want to be able to
also use a tool that you know has
various email templates available okay
you don't want to be stuck with just a
vanilla template again you want to be
able to customize an email for your
audience you want to be able to manage
your list appropriately meaning if you
have 10,000 users or emails in a list
you want to be able to manage them
accordingly you know break them up or or
have sub lists so to speak and then most
importantly you want to make sure you
have a platform that not only does it's
tracking on its own but will give you
some detailed insights meaning you know
what percentage of users open your email
what percentage of recipients clicked on
your email what links they click on you
know which which emails bounced so you
want some detailed insights right in the
platform that you use it it just makes
it more simpler and easier and more
effective to manage you certainly want
to create those smart automated
campaigns meaning you don't even have to
send out the email and then you want to
be able to have some flexibility to set
up email delivery based on a specific
time of day so these tools also while
you - you segment contacts based on
geolocation you want to be able to use a
tool that allows for multivariate
testing again you want to analyze
performance and optimize campaigns you
want to trigger automatic responses
somebody purchases something are you
using a tool that will automatically
that email out so these are all the
reasons why you would use an email
marketing tool so let's dive in and take
a look at an example and we're going to
use MailChimp as our example today so
let's dive in and take a look at
MailChimp
so with MailChimp once you log in you
know you're gonna be able to see some
historical campaigns that you sent out
or are you gonna be able to create your
own campaign and so this is kind of
under campaigns you can kind of see an
overview of the ones you've sent out or
if they're in draft mode you'll be able
to see they're in droplet so you can go
ahead and edit them so here we have one
that was set up on August 26 and it's
still in draft mode so we can go ahead
and edit that so if we just click at it
you know we have the flexibility to you
know pick and choose who we're sending
this to who it's from what the subject
line is and then we can certainly design
the email so if we click design email
again this is important because with
email marketing you want to be able to
cater your email to your intended
audience so if you're selling men's
shoes your audience should be men okay
so you don't want men to receive an
email about women's shoes it sounds like
it's common sense but the point being
you want to be able to use an email
platform that's going to be able to
allow you to put two and two together
the message and the design with the
intended audience and so here you can
see MailChimp allows us to do that okay
you can see some of the layouts here
okay you also have themes that you could
choose from okay you could search for
different themes or you can even just
code your own so you can just paste in
your code in or you can import it
so MailChimp allows that flexibility
you're not stuck with one of their
templates and so if we go back to the
dashboard the one thing I like about
MailChimp though is the reporting okay
so yes it is easy to choose a template
and map
that template to your audience but I
really like the reports that they have
to offer so you know here you can see
there's some list that we've sent to and
we choose one of our audience list then
we can see some really detailed
reporting here and so here I can see
this email that was sent out in June I
could see it was sent to 95,000 plus
subscribers okay of the subscribers I
saw two thousand plus open it and then
157 clicks so I can view this report in
more detail just by clicking on view
report so again we want an email
platform that's gonna be able to give us
some detailed information about how that
email campaign performed and so I can
get down really to the nitty gritty I
can actually see you know I'm the
content what was clicked and what wasn't
clicked so here I sent to different
subject lines so I'm able to compare the
two against one another okay so I can
really go into detail about one of them
here so if I click view report
I can specifically see what the average
for this list is so here I'm able to
compare against the list average and
it's 16% I only had an open rate of 2.5%
so the industry average is 18% and so
here I'm it will see the list average
for the click rate and the industry
average for the click rate as well so
then I can see some specifics about it
how many people unsubscribed then I can
see a graph I can see the top links that
were clicked and the top subscribers
with the most opens I can link social to
it if I want to and then I can see
geographic information so the point
being is MailChimp
really goes into some nice detail here
about the email campaigns and how they
performed so the great thing is to
within mail chip you can link it within
Google Analytics you can link it with
e-commerce okay so if you have an email
and you're you're selling products and
somebody purchase that product MailChimp
is able to integrate in with your
shopping commerce platform for example
we'll call
so if somebody did purchase you can send
out that thank-you email mail chimp even
goes a step further and if somebody did
click on a link go to your shopping cart
add something to the shopping cart and
then abandon the car
you know MailChimp allows you the
opportunity to retarget them via email
so MailChimp is flexible and that's what
you want in an email marketing platform
you want something that's flexible that
you can cater to your audience you can
manage your audience list and you can
get detailed reporting on your different
campaigns for that audience
so that's mill chimp and summary and so
most email platforms do a lot of the
similar features or have some of the
similar features but that's what you
ideally want to look for in an email
marketing platform so here's a tool that
doesn't get talked about enough when it
comes to email marketing and that's
Google's URL builder and the reason why
we're going to talk about this tool
today is because most people in the u.s.
use Google Analytics as their web
analytics tool and the one thing about
Google Analytics is it allows you to
track different campaigns so if you're
doing pay-per-click campaigns outside of
Google you can certainly track the
performance right in Google Analytics
and email is no different so if you're
using Google Analytics and you're
sending out an email let's just say
MailChimp or any other email marketing
platform you want to be able to append
your links with what we call UTM
tracking so for example if I have a URL
that says visit Florida and I'm going to
send out an email I have up to five
parameters that I can use okay so here's
my email or URL that I'm using in the
email so I have up to five parameters
that I can use to track this particular
email so let's go through some of those
parameters so the first one is campaign
source so what's the source of the
campaign well we could certainly
identify MailChimp and for using
MailChimp as the
now the thing about the URL builders you
always want to use lower case because
Google Analytics is case sensitive so as
a rule of thumb just stick with a lower
case so our source is going to be
MailChimp because that's the platform
we're using if you're using you know
Constant Contact or vertical response or
you know some of these other one
convertkit then go ahead and put in that
platform as the source now for the
medium which is the means in which we're
driving traffic to the site let's go
ahead and put in email because that's
what we're using a drive traffic to you
this particular page now what's the
campaign name well we're in summer so
we're gonna call this the summer of
promo so the summer promo here is visit
Florida beaches okay so we're gonna send
this email out to the masses and
particularly not only the masses but the
masses in the north because we're gonna
say hey look come to Florida for the
summer come visit our beaches that's the
point of the campaign so that's what
we're gonna use for the campaign aim is
whatever the campaign is it's a summer
promo now notice I got an asterisk next
to these particular parameters so
Google's asking us hey these are
mandatory so go ahead and put something
in there now for campaign term and
campaign content we could certainly
leave them blank because they're not
mandatory but since we're talking about
email I would certainly recommend that
you use the campaign content parameter
and why do I say that because if we're
sending an email out to say you have
10,000 recipients I want to be able to
split out the email into two segments
one segment that's going to get subject
line one and one segment that's going to
get subject line two so in this case I'm
going to put whatever subject line one
is in the campaign content field so now
I have four parameters and once I've
entered in my variables in this
parameter fields I now have a revised or
appended URL so my original URL was
visit florida.com slash Ian - US last
Florida - beaches dot HTML my original
URL
I've now appended that with some UTM
parameters and now I see my original URL
appended with the UTM parameters based
on those variables so I can copy up just
by clicking the copy URL I can go to my
browser I can paste that URL in there
and I want to check to see if it works
so here I could see this particular page
loaded Florida beaches with my UTM
parameters appended to the URL so that's
for the first subject line that's for
the audience that's going to get the
first subject line I want to do another
one for the second subject line so now
I'm going to change my campaign content
parameter to subject line underscore two
I'm going to copy that URL I'm gonna
check it okay so I can see that the page
loads with those UTM parameters and so
now what am I going to do I'm going to
use the first URL and the second URL in
my email okay so any link that I have in
this case I'm using subject line two so
for the email with the second subject
line going to that segmented audience
this is the link I'm going to use in the
email so if you have one or two or three
links in the email this is the URL
you're going to use because when
somebody clicks on that link you're
gonna be able to see that that click in
Google Analytics so if I jump over to
Google Analytics after I sent out my
email I'm gonna go to acquisition I'm
gonna go to campaigns I'm gonna go to
all campaigns now based on the variables
I put into my parameters meaning source
medium campaign name content or term
that's what I'm going to look for in
Google Analytics so we could start with
source and medium so if I click on
source and medium as my primary
dimension here I can see mailchimp and
the actual dates was used as part of the
variable for for
source and then I what can I see the
medium being email so now I can see for
this email that was sent out in
MailChimp in May I could see how many
users how many sessions and more
importantly how many conversions so we
could certainly hone in on that
particular email if we wanted to if we
choose some of the other parameters
available to us so here I could see the
campaign name okay so I could see
exactly what campaign what source what
email drove in traffic and conversions
and if I'm doing subject line testing I
can choose content as my parameter so
here I'm gonna change it to content and
now I can see the subject lines in this
case if I go back to my source medium
I'm gonna be able to see what subject
lines from my emails generated the most
traffic and not only the most traffic
but also conversions so that's the whole
point behind using the URL builder again
you're taking a URL that you're going to
use an email and then you're going to
pan that URL with different parameters
campaign source campaign medium campaign
aim and then optionally campaign content
and/or campaign term okay once you've
entered variables into those parameters
you're gonna get an appended URL which
you can then use in your email so when
the email gets sent you're gonna go back
over to Google Analytics and you're
going to look at the results of that
campaign of that source of that medium
of that content ie subject line and so
that's why the URL builder is so
important because MailChimp gives us
some good insight as to how the email
performed in terms of open and click
rates but what we really want to see is
how that campaign performed whence it
drove traffic to my website so that's
the whole idea behind the URL builder
using Google Analytics you'll be able to
use the URL builder with whatever email
platform you're using so let's move on
to web analytics tools and this is an
important section because web analytics
tools kind of the central focal point of
all digital marketing and it starts
really with Google Analytics Google
Analytics is a freemium meaning that
they have a free version that you can
use there is also a paid version of
Google Analytics but given the advent of
Google its popularity especially in the
United States a majority of users are
using the free version of Google
Analytics so it's a very popular tool
especially for marketers but there are
also other tools available so it's not
just Google so we have Adobe Analytics
which is also freemium you have
KISSmetrics
you have spring metrics you have YouTube
analytics which is part of Google but
YouTube has its own separate analytics
insights so a lot of these as you can
see are free to use they're available no
reason why you should not be using an
analytics tool to measure your marketing
campaigns or website behavior and why
would we want to use these tools again
well again we want to really measure
behavior we want to measure what's going
on with our website so we want to be
able to identify the location of where
our website visitors are coming from and
a lot of these analytics tools use IP
address to identify the location of a
website visitor so if you're trying to
target a specific country then you want
to be able to see that the visitors to
your website are coming from that
specific country or location we also
want to measure the engagement of our
website behavior so we get traffic to
the website what are they doing how long
are they staying what pages are they
visiting so this is the overall nature
of really why we want to use web
analytics to measure how successful our
website is at treating our website
visitors with the same courtesy you
would if you had a brick and mortar
store somebody comes into your store you
want
to find what they're looking for quickly
you want them to be happy with their
experience you certainly want them to
pay for the products very quickly and
easily and efficiently and you want them
to come back and that's no different
than a website so we want our website to
perform in a manner that's going to suit
our audience and that's why we want to
track engagement so why else well we
want to really look at who's coming are
they returning visitors or new visitors
you know ideally you want a nice mix
between 50% new and 50% we're returning
because you know returning visitors are
loyal there's some loyalty to that they
already know your brand they're coming
back to your website new visitors are
curious and you want new visitors
because that means more traffic so you
want a nice balance between that
analytics tools will help you measure
that you want to be able to measure
organic traffic whether you like it or
not whether you know it or not but
Google and other search engines are
indexing your pages and your pages are
being found via the search engines and
so you want to be able to measure how
much traffic you're actually generating
from those search engines we talked
about this with email marketing and UTM
tracking so if you set up email
campaigns or non Google campaigns you
want to use UTM tracking and Google
Analytics and other analytics tools but
specifically Google Analytics will help
you see the results of your campaigns if
they're tracked with UTM tracking so
that's another good reason why to use a
web analytics tool probably most
importantly amongst all these bullet
points is our goals or website
conversions we want to be able to see
how much traffic is coming to our
website and not only the engagement of
the traffic but how much of that traffic
is actually doing what we want them to
do ie are they converting and we want to
optimize our sites and channels
performance so the whole idea of
collecting all this information is that
you could turn around and improve
performance so if your bounce rate is
high well how do you lower bounce rate
well we need to do something about that
analytics tools will help us identify
what's not working from our site
perspective and from a channel
perspective and we can take action to
improve performance so that's the whole
idea behind optimizing our site's
performance so let's jump into Google
Analytics and let's take a look at
everything we just talked about in those
bullet points so about improving website
performance measuring engagement looking
at our goals and conversions measuring
campaigns with UTM tracking all those
good things that we can get in a good
analytics tool so Adobe Mixpanel
bring metrics you know they all work in
a similar fashion and that they're
really measuring website behavior and so
if we're in Google Analytics really what
we're doing is we're measuring the
performance of our website broken down
into four components audience
acquisition behavior and conversions so
what do we want to do well we want to
look into each one of these sections so
let's start with audience and so
audience and google analytics tells us
who is coming to our website now they're
not gonna specifically tell us hey Rob
Sanders came to your website but they
are going to say that somebody from San
Francisco California came to the website
and these are the pages they looked at
and this is the language and they came
from this device and they're a returning
user so they're paying a picture for you
okay so they're not giving you a list of
names that would not be legal but they
are providing you with a good picture of
who is coming and when I say picture we
have to paint that picture and so if we
look at say demographics for example and
I got a demographics overview here's a
picture I'm painting well I can see that
25 to 34 year olds are the majority of
the age group that is coming to my
website okay I can see on the gender
side of it I can see that 63% of my
traffic and again this is year-to-date
that I'm looking at is coming to my
website so two-thirds of my traffic is
female 1/3 male and they're between the
ages of 25 and 34 so I'm painting a
picture about you know gender and age
coming to my website well I can also
look at geo so where specifically might
these people be coming from so if I go
to location under geo I'm gonna be able
to see a breakdown of country or I can
even hone it down to city or specific
location and here I can see United
States is the primary driver but not by
much so we have 16 almost 17 percent
from the US and then 16 percent from
Argentina 13 percent from Mexico 10
percent from India so we have a nice mix
of traffic from different locations in
the world coming to our website so
that's Gio but more importantly let's
take a look at mobile so if we get a
mobile overview how are people coming to
our website are they on a desktop or
laptop are they using their mobile
device are they using a tablet and so
Google Analytics breaks it down very
nice for you and so we could see
percentages and actual numbers by device
category and so in this case I can see
year-to-date
I can see 62% are coming from desktop
35% are coming from mobile and so that's
important because most people start
their journey from mobile and that is
growing and that's going to continue to
grow so you want to keep an eye on
mobile so to me this is one of the more
important reports under audience because
people who come from mobile have a
different not only experience because
the website should be responsive to the
mobile device but their mindset is going
to be different they're actively looking
for something they're probably going to
either then follow up on their desktop
or follow up in person at your store or
they're probably looking for directions
or they may just call you so the
experience is a lot different on mobile
so we want to hone in on the growth of
mobile okay so to me this is one of the
more important report
and Google Analytics especially under
audience so let's move on to acquisition
so acquisition reporting tells us how
the traffic was driven to the website so
if audience tells us who is coming to
the web site acquisition tells us how
that traffic got to the website and so
really what you want to do is get a
sense of what channels what marketing
channels are driving traffic so remember
we talked about organic search while
those search engines are indexing your
pages well how much of that traffic from
the search engines is actually coming to
your site and I'm a believer in if
organic search is the primary driver of
traffic then you have a pretty healthy
website because that means the search
engines are indexing your pages people
are searching for something related to
your business you're being found you're
getting clicked and that represents a
majority of the traffic so that's always
a good thing so here we could see it
broken down my channel if I go to all
traffic channels report I can see in my
dimension that organic search represents
72% of my traffic when this is a year
today then I can see paid search then I
can see direct which means somebody went
directly to the site I could see
referral email social then I could see
more paid search broken out so these are
the different marketing channels now
analytics allows you to look at a
specific source and medium so the source
would be the actual website or search
engine in the medium would differentiate
how that traffic actually got to the
site so if we're talking about a search
engine did they come to the site via
paid search or did they come to the site
via organic search and so all we need to
do is change our primary dimension from
default channel grouping to source a
medium and we can see specifically the
break out of the different sources and
mediums driving traffic to the site so
here I can see Google organic at 71
percent and in Google CPC or cost per
click at 50
16% of our traffic so then I can look
down I could see email in here Bing
organic I could see some referring sites
I could see some social in terms of
mobile Facebook okay so we could see a
mix of the different sources and mediums
driving traffic to the site okay so you
don't always have to look at channel per
se you can look at it via source and
medium and if you're running Google ads
under acquisition analytics has a whole
section of Google ads reporting so if
you're running campaigns on Google ads
remember we looked at the keyword
planner in Google Ads so if you're
running campaigns on Google ads you can
certainly see the performance of those
campaigns just by clicking on campaigns
we can also see campaigns other
campaigns that we're running so remember
that UTM tracking that we set up for
email well we want to be able to track
the performance of email and any other
non Google campaign with UTM tracking so
when we do that we'll be able to go to
campaigns all campaigns and we'll be
able to see the campaign performance if
we look at source and medium we'll be
able to see what campaigns drove traffic
to the website so here I can see
vertical response email as a driver of
traffic so that's the campaign reporting
and then also if you have search console
so we looked at search console earlier
when we talk about SEO tools well
remember I said you can link up search
console with Google Analytics
well here's search console and we could
see queries devices landing pages
countries so all the performance metrics
that we could see in search console
because we haven't linked up with
analytics we could see it right here so
this gives us a nice snapshot of what
keywords are driving traffic to the site
organically I could see the impressions
I could see the clicks then I can see
the clicked array and then the average
position so in theory the higher
something ranks the more traffic you're
going to get so that's the idea behind
it we
to make sure that we're ranking for our
coveted keywords and if we are we want
to be able to measure how many times our
listing was seen and how many times it
was clipped so that's the great thing
about you know Google they have a family
of products and those products tend to
talk to one another in the form of
Google search console and Google Ads you
can connect them directly to Google
Analytics so let's move from acquisition
to behavior so here in behavior we have
a number a different report so behavior
tells us once the traffic actually
arrived at the website how are they
behaving and so really what I would do
is from there go to site content all
pages and so this gives us an idea of
how many pages were actually viewed so
site content all pages tells us what
page and how many times it was viewed
during a period of time and again we're
looking at year today so I can see
engagement related metrics associated
with a page so this particular page here
on line one I could see how many pages
unique pages which is equal to sessions
so I can have a session come to the
website and look at a page multiple
times in that session I could see the
average time the person has spent on a
page and I can also see the bounce rate
so a bounce rate indicates that they
arrived on the page and didn't go any
further they left the website from that
page that they arrived on and so I can
also see percentage of exits meaning
what page did people exit the site from
so these are all engagement related
metrics so here is where I want to react
and optimize my website performance so I
see I see a page not performing well
meaning it has a high bounce rate or
maybe low time on page then I'm probably
going to optimize it meaning test it or
change it to improve performance so
these are all pages but I could
certainly look at landing pages
okay so landing pages tells us the
behavior of the page once somebody
landed
so a landing page means that somebody
came from organic search or paid search
or another channel landed on this page
so here I can see this particular page
on line one at 4970 sessions okay and I
can also see the performance of that
page
so measuring engagements against pages
is definitely important because pages
and performing in terms of bounce rate
or time on page then we want to be able
to make changes to that page to improve
performance okay there are some other
great reports under behavior so we want
to go to site speed we want to look at
how fast or how slow our pages load so
this is important from an SEO
perspective because if a page isn't
loading very fast then chances of it
getting ranked in Google are not very
good so Google's organic search
basically takes page load time seriously
so if a page doesn't look very fast then
we need to be able to fix it so we can
go to page timings I can get a good
sense of the average page load time of a
particular page and what Google does
here is under speed suggestions they
actually will give me some ideas and
speed suggestions on how to address a
page that's loading very slow and so
when we load up the speed suggestions
report what Google does and say hey we
know that this page is loading very slow
the average page load time is 15 seconds
here's some suggestions we're going to
give you seven suggestions so if you
click on that what's actually going to
happen is you're going to go to another
tool called PageSpeed insights and
PageSpeed insights is analyzing the page
as you can see here and when it's done
analyzing the page it's going to give
you some feedback on how to improve page
load performance not only for desktop
but for mobile so here I can see if I
scroll down this is desktop and these
are some of the opportunities that I can
address when trying to improve the page
load
of that particular page so here I could
see there's some server response time
issues image sizes probably need to be
resized I can remove unused CSS okay so
there are a lot of different things I
can do to improve the page load time on
this particular page okay this is for
desktop I can also see mobile so mobile
a lot of the same issues so if we
address these these opportunities then
we could see a lift in page load time we
see lift in page load time we're going
to probably see a lift in organic
rankings or even user engagement because
if a page takes a long time to load a
user is probably not going to stay on
that page very long so to me site speed
is an important report under behavior
now one more report here that I want to
point out under behavior is events and
to me events are important so if you're
trying to measure engagement on your
website you need to make sure you have a
vent tracking setup and when we talk
about event tracking we're talking about
measuring things that analytics doesn't
measure by default so if you have a
button on your website if you have a PDF
download if you have a submit button on
a form submission if you have a
subscribe button if you have a video if
you have an external link anything that
is going to trigger engagement on your
website you need to measure with event
tracking and event tracking is simply
set up by breaking out the event into a
category and action in the label and so
here we can see for our particular
website we have categories already set
up for event tracking so here for
example I can see on line six video I
could see how many people actually
watched our video okay so here's the
action video start okay so over this
period of time I could see I had 49
unique events 50 total so that's how
many people actually watched the video
and you can always report to label and
that'll tell you what page people
watched
in this case the video so event tracking
is important because we want to be able
to measure engagement so if we go to
events under behavior and you don't see
any events listed you probably need to
get that set up and mat is set up
through Google tag manager so what you
want to do is you want to be able to set
up your events through Google tag
manager which is another Google platform
but you certainly want to do that so
that's where you set up your events when
you set up your events for your website
with a category in action and label
you'll be able to measure those events
in analytics under behavior under events
and the important thing here is you'll
be able to measure engagement so I'll be
able to see how many people came to the
site and how many people clicked on a
button downloaded a PDF submitted a form
played a video did whatever we wanted
them to do so events are important so
let's move from behavior to conversions
and this is important because we want to
be able to measure conversions on a
website so analytics has four types of
conversions so if I go to admin down at
the bottom and then I go to goals I can
see that I have four different types of
goals that I can use now right now I
have event related to goals set up for
the website for this particular website
so we just talked about event tracking
so if you're measuring a button click on
your website you can certainly turn that
into a goal and so all you need to do is
tell analytics hey this is the
particular category this is the
particular action so for example if I
click on this particular goal and take a
look at it I can see that we have a
category set up that anything that
resembles donate now okay or donate go
ahead and fire this
as a conversion okay so event is one
type of goal another type of goal is
destination so if somebody goes to a
specific page like a confirmation page
we can turn that into a goal so here I
can see if somebody goes to donation -
confirmation then analytics is going to
fire that goal as a conversion and we're
gonna see a conversion against a
different metric or a different
dimension like channel or audience ok so
destination is the second type of goal
the third type of goal is duration so
how long did somebody stay on my website
so in this example if they stayed at
least 1 minute 30 seconds or more then
analytics is going to count that as a
goal conversion okay so if duration is
the third type and then the fourth type
is pages per session okay so if I look
at this example here if a user can to my
website and looked at more than three
pages in that particular session then
analytics is gonna fire a goal
conversion so four types of goals you
don't have to set up all four different
types
my recommendation is least have one goal
set up if you're not sure what goal to
set up then at least set up a duration
or pages per session okay so at least
you can measure how long somebody stays
on your website or how many pages they
went to okay so when you actually do
have these goals set up you can go back
into conversions we can go back into
goals we can go back into overview and
we can measure our goal completions over
this period of time so here I could see
313 goal completions total with a goal
conversion rate of 1.8% and then I could
see it broken down by gold type so
remember the only goals I have available
and set up our event related goals so 69
newsletter signups 156 donate click
buttons I have 32 contact form
submissions 37 email click completions
and then 11 phone
or click completions so I can measure
engagement as a goal and so goals
generally are important to the business
so you want to make sure that if you
have a goal for your website then you
want to be able to set that up as a goal
in Google Analytics so that way when
you're looking at example channels if I
go back to my channels report I can then
measure channel by goal conversion so
these are all goals but if I want to
look at for example how many people from
organic search clicked on the donate Now
button I could see that I can see a year
today ten thousand eight hundred eighty
seven users which meant eleven thousand
sessions seventy-six clicked on that
donate Now button and that comes out to
0.65 percent conversion rate okay so
that's important so you want to be able
to measure any dimension whether that be
channel source medium keyword campaign
mobile device could be demographic
gender or age you want to be able to
measure any dimension against the goals
you have set up so you can measure
performance and that also includes pages
or landing pages as well so that's a
quick overview of what you can expect to
see in Google Analytics again audience
acquisition behavior and conversions
there are a lot of data in Google
Analytics but you want to be able to
take advantage of the data in order to
improve website performance now let's
jump over to YouTube analytics because
if you have videos on YouTube if you
have a channel set up some playlists
you'll be able to get some really good
insights as to how your videos
performing and so here I could see I'm
in YouTube all I did was I went to my
account then I went to the beta the
studio version of YouTube and then from
there I went to analytics so my account
YouTube studio analytics and analytics
here is going to give me all sore
some information about my videos okay so
here I could see over the last 28 days
my video has produced over 8,600 views
my watch time in minutes totaled over
17,000 and I met at 48 subscribers and
this is an overall okay so I can
actually see when I publish videos and I
can see the date they were published and
here I'm looking at you know total views
over this particular date range I can
also see specifics on a particular video
so I could see the top video in terms of
minutes here I could see this particular
video had 602 minutes over the last 28
days so here I could see views on a
particular video so this is just an
overview I could certainly look at some
other information if I click on reach
viewers I could see the total impression
so how many times my video was viewed or
how many people looked at it okay and
then the click-through rate so here I
can see the different traffic sources so
29% came externally okay here I can see
25% came within YouTube itself I could
see how many times the video is viewed
and played via playlist via suggested
video so I could see different ways in
which the traffic found my video and
actually watched it here I could see
externally how people were able to file
my videos and I could see 46% found it
via Google search see some lots of
information here about sources of
traffic how the traffic got to these
videos so I could see then once the
traffic found my videos how many times
they actually saw it and viewed it and
then watched it so that's how many times
I was able to reach viewers via
different sources and then their
reaction to that how many times they saw
it and watched it here I can click on
interest viewers so again I could see
the top videos in terms of watch time I
could see the top playlist so here I can
see my partners play
with the top playlist so I can see some
interest here in terms of average view
duration and then here we have build an
audience so we can look at specific
audiences if we have been built in
YouTube to see how many people actually
watch my videos so here I can see 88% of
the people who watched my videos over
the last 28 days were not even
subscribed so that tells me a lot of
people are finding my videos spending
some time watching them they're not
subscribed so we're trying to get them
to subscribe to our channel so they can
watch more so a lot of information here
in YouTube itself about how our video is
performed again this is good insight
because ideally what you want to do is
you really want to take a look at a
specific video see how its performing so
if I just click on one particular video
I can actually see the audience
retention over the course of the video
itself I could see the ways in which
people found the video ok again
externally or via YouTube search I could
see how many people liked it or disliked
it I could see all sorts of information
on a particular video itself or an
overview of my channel so that's all
available to you in YouTube analytics
under YouTube studio so take advantage
of that if you're publishing videos on a
regular basis you want to hone in on how
your videos are performing so if you
have any additional questions about
YouTube analytics or YouTube in general
take a look at our video that we created
earlier this year about how to create a
YouTube channel we go into some in-depth
insights into YouTube itself especially
YouTube analytics so take a look at that
video and if you have any other insights
about YouTube analytics or analytics in
general go ahead and put a comment below
this video so let's turn our attention
to competitor spying tools very
important to keep tabs on what the
competition's doing and there are a lot
of tools out there so when it comes to
social we can use a freemium tool like
sprout social
listen in on our competitors we can use
another freemium tool socialblade
there's a popular tool out there called
spyfu that's freemium as well Mazz we
looked at Maas earlier for keyword and
organic Maas is a great tool for also
leveraging our competitors in terms of
backlinks and buzzsumo so that's another
free tool get there lots of tools out
there these are just examples of some of
the tools that we use here at simply
lerner and I use personally and
professionally to get a sense of what
our competition is doing so why would we
want to use a competitor spine tool well
it may sound like a very straightforward
question but there are lots of reasons
why and so let's look at some of these
reasons and the first reasons we really
want to identify you know our
competitors backlinks and monitor
changes in their ranking so the reason
why we have this is the top bullet point
is because SEO organic search is a
long-term strategy on page off page
website very technical and creative
there's a lot going on with SEO a lot
going on and sometimes it takes a long
time to rank for something and a lot of
SEO does depend on relevancy relevancy
being hominy quality backlinks are
linked to you so it's always good to
leverage what your competitors are doing
so you can see how you stack up and so
that's why this is up there as number
one we want to be able to really take a
look at what our competitors are doing
another example would be hey how much
traffic a competitor's gaining on
certain keywords this could go either
way for paid search organic search what
a competitor is bidding on are they
really getting traffic from those
keywords so there are tools out there
that help us leverage what our
competition is doing okay we can also
identify our competitors top performing
content for relevant topics and we can
determine what our competitors website
referral traffic is okay we can pull our
competitors data and compare it with our
own campaigns so lots of tools out there
to help you do this and we may want to
track the total amount of clicks a
competitor receive
and how much they pay for each keyword
so let's go on able to take a look at a
few examples how we can leverage all
these bullet points that we just
discussed and so we're gonna start out
with sprout social and sprout socials a
tool I use it's a social media platform
there's a lot of things you can do with
sprout social definitely generate
reports for your social media platforms
you could set up post that get published
at a certain time and day but there's
also one particular tool in here called
listening and so what we could do is we
just put in for example RV rentals in
Twitter so what we're doing is we're
actually listening to see who else is
tweeting about RV rentals so we could do
this for Twitter we could do it Facebook
some other social media platforms the
whole idea here on sprout social is to
get a sense of what our competitors are
doing so we could have easily put in a
brand name we're just going general here
because we want to rank for the keyword
RV rentals and so here we could take a
look at you know with some of these
particular brands are doing like go RV
rentals cruise America RV we can see
just scroll down and we can get a sense
of in particular what people are
tweeting about one of the companies are
tweeting when it comes to this
particular keyword RV rentals now if I
want to hone in on a particular
competitor I could just really refine my
search for that competitors brand name
so RV share so here I could take a look
at you know what they're doing when
they're posting or tweeting how long ago
the time of day get an idea of what
they're actually saying what campaigns
they're promoting ok I can get a sense
of everything about this tweet and so
here I can scroll down and I can see
what's been shared by other people for
this particular brand and I can see a
lot of people are as an example
retweeting this particular giveaway and
so to me it just gives me a sense in
this particular example on Twitter as to
what our competitors doing ok let's
start our attention to SC
so remember a first bullet point we want
to get a sense of what our competitors
are doing when it comes to backlinks and
so Moz has a great tool called link
Explorer and link Explorer there allows
us to actually compare link profiles so
for my domain I can go ahead and put my
competitors domains in there and
definitely get a sense of you know - how
many links my competitors have external
Intel or internal I can get a sense of
the domain Authority I can get a sense
of page Authority linking domains so I
can really do a comparison across my
domain and my competitors domains to get
a snapshot of how I compare against my
competitors so this gives me an overview
of everything I need to know organically
now Moz also has another great tool
under link Explorer called link
intersect and I like link intersect I
use it a lot because if our competitors
really have a number of external links
and domains pointing to their site may
have a better of domain Authority and
page Authority then you know I want to
be able to you know see what they're
doing where they're linking who's
linking to them I want to get be able to
get a snapshot of why is their domain so
much better than ours in terms of
authority and so the link intersect
actually allows me to do that so I can
go ahead and put my competitors domains
in there and then I can find
opportunities and so you just click on
opportunities and you can see where my
site intersects with their site and if
it doesn't actually intersect then I
have an opportunity to actually try and
get a link on that particular site so
that's what the link intersect report
does it allows me see where my links
intersect with my competitors and if it
doesn't intersect then I have an
opportunity to generate a backlink
so that's ideally what the Linnet link
intersect tool is in Moz it allows me to
really get a sense of you know where I'm
linking and
my competitor linking now what we can
also do is also take advantage of
another report under mozzies link
explorer and the discovered and lost
report so we could put an r domain or we
could put even our competitors domain in
there and we can get a sense of what
domains were found and linked to them so
really within Moz we can get a good
snapshot I have what web sites are
linking to our competitors we get a good
snapshot of the overall links to our
competitor sites and specifically with
sites so the whole idea is if it's good
for our competitors meaning they're
linking from a site that has a good
domain Authority and Louis spam score
then it's probably a site I want to be
able to tackle as well okay so you have
discovered and lost okay you have
comparing link profiles and you have
link intersect so those are three good
reports you can leverage right in
mozzies link Explorer tool now there's
one more report we can leverage in Moz
and that's the inbound links report and
so we can go ahead and type in our
competitors domain here and again we can
get a snapshot of what their domain
Authority is page Authority for the home
page but really this is what we're after
linking domains so this particular
domain has over 9,000 linking domains so
what we can do is actually go through
and see based on domain Authority I
could sort by domain Authority where
these pages are being linked from and so
here I can see read it read it read it
so a lot of Reddit here which is a good
site for backlinking New York Times so
you know there's a lot of different
sites here Washington Post so I can get
a good snapshot on my competitor by
seeing every link that's pointing to
them now of course I don't want to go
through 9,000 links I can really just
hone in on a specific link source or
link type or link state so I can really
filter it if I wanted to I can export
the report and do some further analysis
but really the whole idea here as I
could see what URL is
linking to this particular competitor
site what the anchor text is what the
page and domain authority is so this
gives me a really really good insight on
all the back linking that my competitor
has and again if I'm trying to catch my
competitor it's probably not a bad idea
to look at what they're doing even copy
what they're doing in terms of
backlinking so we're knowing on reddit
then we probably need to be on reddit
because if that's where our competitor
is and they're getting good link juice
from reddit which has a domain authority
of 90 then hey if it's good for the
goose it's good for the gander so they
say so inbound links isn't just another
good report you can leverage in Moz
under the link Explorer reporting tool
now if I want to get a good snapshot as
to what my competitors doing on search
exactly well look no further than spyfu
so spyfu is a another tool that you can
leverage from a PPC SEO perspective you
know from an SEO perspective you got
some backlinking data as well just like
you did in Moz from a PPC perspective
you can get some good keyword insights
and so here I just went ahead and typed
in the domain and what this is going to
do is just give me an overall snapshot
for my competitors domain so here I
could see you know how many organic
keywords there found for the estimated
monthly SEO clicks they're getting based
on the volume of those keywords okay I
could see here the keywords their top
competitors also rank for the rank
history 12 years so this particular
domains been around a long time okay so
that's on the organics I can flip over
to the page side and I could see that
they are doing paid search I could see
5,000 plus keywords they're betting on
hey based on that what they're actually
paying and then I could see you know
some of the other competitors listed
here from a paid perspective and an
organic perspective I could see the
shared keyword overlap and now again you
can pay for this because it's freemium
and get some really good insights as to
how your domain
here's to your competitors so I'm using
the free version and here the free
version spyfu just giving me some
overall data on the specific domain I
entered in and so I entered in my
competitors you can certainly enter in
your own domain to get a sense of
organic keywords and paid keywords so
you can see top keywords top paid
keywords okay this is Google Ads okay so
this is what recommendations as to what
to purchase okay here you can see some
even some at Google Ads history I can
see exactly what ad copy my competitor
actually wrote and for what keyword and
then I can see some organic ranking
history here as I keep scrolling down
this overview report so I can see for RV
rent where they rank and then I can see
inbound links just like I did in Moz
spyfu is providing me with some insight
as to hey what links are pointing to
them and what the domain strength is and
how many clicks they expect to receive
so this is all free data take it or
leave it but it's all free data
available to you under spyfu so spike
view gives you kind of an overview for
free some really in-depth analysis if
you actually pay for it and it just
really hones in on what your competitors
are bidding for paid wise and what
they're ranking for Organic wise and so
spyfu is a really good tool to leverage
if you just want to get a snapshot of
how your competitor overlaps with you so
let's turn our attention to Google
Analytics
because in Google Analytics under
audience I can go to benchmarking and
basically the benchmarking reports
allows me to see what the industry as a
whole is doing compared to my own
website now the caveat here on this
particular report is that it's all
anonymous status so I can't exactly see
what competitor is doing what in this
report but if I hone in on my industry
in this case autos & vehicles and I hone
in on a specific country or adjust the
size of the daily sessions that
get then I could see hey analytics in
this case in this example and sharing
eight thousand eight hundred sixty three
web properties okay so they're sharing
the data for over eight thousand web
properties and I can compare those web
properties against my own so for all in
the same industry it gives me a sense
here as to how I stack up against the
industry as a whole in this case as it
pertains to channels so you can see here
red not good Green is good so in the
industry we're not doing as good as
others in the same industry who are
receiving the same amount of sessions
now we could certainly adjust and we can
adjust our locale and if we do that
Google's going to be able to adjust how
many web properties are actually
contributing to the report and so when
analytics makes that adjustment we're
gonna be able to see in this case just
New Zealand so we're gonna adjust for
New Zealand and we're gonna go with the
4999 and so we could see there are about
you know 300 something web properties
contributing 47 web properties now
contributing to this report
so for focused on the New Zealand region
and this is the amount of traffic we get
we're now comparing us against 47 other
anonymous web properties so now if I go
back to the report after I've honed in
I'm looking at channels and I can see
how many sessions were getting by
channels and how I compare against the
competition I can also measure up
against percentage of new sessions new
users pages per session and recession
duration bounce rate so that's just
channels I can also do location and
devices so the whole idea behind this
report is yes you're not honing in on a
particular competitor but you're honing
in on your industry so you're getting a
good idea as to how you compare against
your industry just by making some
adjustments in the benchmarking report
you obviously want to make sure you're
looking at the same industry adjust for
your country or region adjust for the
site size meaning
how many sessions you I should get on a
daily basis and then analytics will do
the rest
they'll compare you against those in
your industry and so I find this to be a
good tool because it allows me to stack
up our site against those in the
industry and obviously if we're not
driving as many sessions especially safe
from organic then we have our work cut
out for us
okay so that's the whole idea behind the
benchmarking report now if you want to
get some good insight as to what the
competitors are doing and you don't want
to use a tool well look no farther you
can always go to google.com okay so this
is how we used to do it back in the day
before all these tools became available
you just typed in a keyword and we're
gonna type in RV rentals and now we're
gonna be able to see who's bidding on
that keyword so we could see we have a
number of different companies bidding on
the keyword we're interested in okay
here I can see some featured snippets
okay and then I could see some organic
search results okay if I scroll down
I'll be able to see some other companies
bidding on that same keyword meaning
they're paying for RV rentals so if I
clicked on somebody's link here they're
actually going to pay Google for the
click and so this just gives me a good
sense of you know how many people are
actually trying to rank for this keyword
or trying to be found for this keyword
so that's all I did I just did a search
now from an organic perspective if you
really want to hone in on your
competition you can always do this in
text all in title call in and then hit
enter so now I could see I have a
hundred and sixty-three thousand results
and what does that tell me that tells me
that I have a hundred sixty-three
thousand websites with RV rentals in the
title tag so if you're trying to
optimize for the keyword RV rentals as
an example then you know that you have a
hundred and sixty three thousand
different listings ahead of you that you
need to jump over in order to rank for
the keyword RV rentals so using the
all-in title syntax and the keyword
right after that actually just gives you
a more
accurate picture of how many sites are
actually ahead of you for particular
keyword so that's the whole idea so if I
get rid of the syntax and you can see
for RV rentals I have I'm through two
million but that's not really accurate
because not all these listings have the
keyword RV rentals in the title tag and
title tag if you're working on organic
search is one of the key important
factors for ranking so you need to have
that keyword in the title tag so that's
the whole idea behind using the all in
title syntax it gives us a good idea as
to what our competition is doing and how
many sites we have to jump over to get
to number one on google now if you're
running Google ads just as we did with
RV rentals we went up there and we saw
we type that in as a query and we saw
how many advertisers there were for RV
rentals now if we are running our own
campaigns Google ads actually has a good
report that I really like it's called
election insights and so you can get to
auction insights just by clicking on
campaigns and then from campaigns click
on auction insights and when auction
insights allows us to see is what
competitors or domains are bidding on
the same keywords we are and so what
Google does here is it allows us to
actually see where we stack up against
our competition for all the keywords
we're bidding on and so here I'm looking
at year to date and here we could see us
and I can see our competitors okay so I
can see impression share so for if we're
talking about one keyword every keyword
has a hundred percent of pressure share
how much of that impression sure are you
getting and when we say impression share
meaning eyeballs when we talk about
eyeballs are we getting a majority of
the eyeballs or our competitors getting
majority of the eyeballs so we can see
our average position I can see how often
I overlap with my competitors okay I can
see how often I'm above a particular
competitor I can see what percentage I'm
at the top of the page versus my
competitors the absolute top of page
rate and then I can see how often I
outrank my competitors and vice versa
how often my competitors outrank
me so I can see all this good insight as
to what competitors are bidding on the
same keywords I am okay so this is if
you're running Google Ads okay so if
you're running Google Ads okay you can
just click on the auction insights
report you can find them at the top
navigation just by clicking on campaigns
and by doing so you'll be able to gain
some insights as to where you stack up
from a paid search perspective against
your competitors so let's turn our
attention to paid marketing tools so if
you're doing some advertising on Google
Bing LinkedIn you probably want to work
within those platforms as the tool of
choice so you know if you're doing paid
search on say Google search comm or
display you could be doing display
advertising on you know a network like
ad roll or Google or you could be doing
social media paid ads say on Facebook so
whatever it is you're doing you probably
want to work within that platform itself
to get the ideal data that you need okay
so here are some of the tools some of
the places you can go of course if
you're working Google Ads you also have
Google Ads
editor that you can leverage okay and
I'll show you that in a couple minutes
you have Google ads keyword planner of
course both of these are paid if you're
running campaigns
okay so Bing if you're running campaigns
on bing okay you get all this good data
that you can digest these some reporting
okay you also have some third-party
tools out there that you also have to
pay for in word stream okay so were
streams a third-party tool that you can
leverage Bing and Google our actual
advertising network so you would
advertise on the platform itself and get
all the data you need right in the
platform and leverage a lot of the tools
that they have available in the platform
as I mentioned you could also use Google
Ads
editor so Bing also has their own editor
as well so
as well as Facebook so you can use an
editor type version and I'll show you
that here in a couple minutes but let's
talk about why we want to use the tools
in the platform itself well we want to
be able to monitor how our ads
performing so which ad receives the most
traffic as an example we want to
identify keywords that are performing
for us okay so our keywords converting
not converting or they cost us a lot of
money and not netting a high enough
return for us so we want to keep an eye
on that okay so we want to monitor our
cost okay across different locations and
devices not only cost but we want to
also monitor our ads a performing across
different locations and devices keywords
across different locations and devices
so we want to be able to measure by
device okay so we also want to analyze
competitors data and as we showed you in
the competitor section Google as an
example has auction insights reporting
analytics has benchmarking so Google
itself does provide some information in
the case of auction insights as to how
your competitors are performing against
you on Google search so that's on the
paid search side then you have display
okay so display advertisements okay
you're across a different network so
there are different types of networks
out there for example Admiral okay you
know CATIA sell try is another paid
version of or pay tool you can use in
wide orbit so these are some of the paid
marketing tools you can leverage of
course I like to stay if I'm advertising
on Google I like to stay in Google ads
and measure my display performance that
way but if you're on a draw for example
then you want to leverage Admirals
reporting platform and some of the tools
they have to offer so if we look at
display why do we want to leverage some
of these tools well just like search for
example where we want to look at keyword
at a performance same kind of concept
here we want to be able to monitor
whether we have the right keywords and
right customer engagement so when it
comes to display we want to be able to
make sure we're choosing the right
audience of course that means looking at
not only audience insights but our
target insights as well are we reaching
the right audience when it comes to
display and Google has a good break down
that I'm gonna be able to show you here
in a couple minutes
okay so we want to improve our campaigns
by monitoring our competitors display
ads as well so there are tools available
that'll help you do that and that's on
the display side and if we look at
social okay-y what tools can we use on
social well you've got Facebook Ads
manager okay you got a distress Oh quiet
weepy get all these cool paid search
tools again I usually stick with where
I'm advertising so if I'm advertising on
LinkedIn or Twitter I'm gonna leverage
that platform but just know that there
are other tools available for you so a
social like display it's all about
targeting our audience
so for these some of the tools like on
Facebook we can review and relaunch our
ad campaigns based on target audience we
can measure conversions and gain
insights in this example about Facebook
users how are our users interacting with
our ads and then we want to target
people based on their activities such as
purchase intent device usage travel
preferences etc so social Wow's us to do
that and then with Facebook as an
example we can monitor any a/b test we
run for example if a running
call-to-action test we can measure the
results that write in Facebook and I'm
gonna show you an example of that here
shortly so let's jump right into Google
Ads and look at some tools available to
us from the search side of the house so
for running search campaigns writing
Google Ads we could see campaign data we
can see keyword data we could see ad
data so for example if I want to see
what ads are performing I'm just gonna
click on my ads and extensions okay and
here are my ads and now I could see what
ads are performing and
terms of clicks click-through rates etc
and so that way I can go ahead and pause
ads activate ads so that's right here in
the Google ads platform itself now if I
want to look at specific keywords I can
do that so I can see what keywords are
driving traffic and clicks here I could
just sort by clicks and now I can see
not only what keywords are driving
clicks I could see what the
click-through rate is I can see the
impressions how many people actually
viewed my ad after click typing in a
keyword query that I'm bidding on I
could see how much I've paid by keyword
and more importantly I want to be able
to see conversions or conversion rate
and then with Google Ads you have
quality sports so we want to be able to
measure quality score so this is a
Google Ads
keyword reporting and so the great thing
about the keyword reporting is that
there's some other features available to
me here so here I can add negative
keywords okay just by clicking on
negative keywords I can also see a
search terms report and so when it comes
to search terms I can actually see what
specific keywords people typed in and
based on the keyword that somebody typed
in as a query I can see what match type
triggered that particular ad and so if I
see a keyword query that I don't
particularly care to be shown for or
well my ads shown for then I can go
ahead and just select it and I can add
it as a negative keyword okay so that
tool is available to you right in Google
Ads okay then you have the auction
insights so we've reviewed the auction
insights when we're looking at
competitive analysis and so here if we
look at the auction insights we'll be
able to adjust our date range and we'll
be able to see basically you know who
else is bidding on the keywords and what
the impression share is what their
average position is what their overlap
rate is position above rate top a page
absolute top of page right now ranking
shoe so once we have Google has
ADA then they'll be able to share that
information with you okay so that's just
keywords but there's a cool tool that I
really like and I leverage it for SEO
and pay-per-click and that's Google's
keyword planner so if you click on tools
and they click on keyword planner we'll
be able to leverage the keyword planner
and the whole idea behind the keyword
planner is do we want to discover new
keywords or for the keywords we have
selected we can get volume and forecast
on that so here let's type in a keyword
mail delivery and if I click get
started' okay so Google's going to give
me some other keyword ideas and they're
gonna give me what the average monthly
searches are for that keyword they're
gonna let me know the competition
they're gonna give me a range in terms
of how much I can expect to pay for that
keyword so if I happen to click on that
keyword I can add it to a plan and then
once I've added to a plan then I can go
ahead and look at that plan and measure
what kind of volume I'm gonna get and
how much I can expect to pay so now once
I've added my keyword to that plan I can
go ahead and see how many clicks and
impressions and costs and click the raid
an average cost per click I can expect
to spend so and this is based on a
maximum CPC of $2 so I can go ahead and
adjust my plan accordingly
if I want to in order to see basically
how much I can expect to spend so that's
the whole idea behind the keyword
planner in terms of choosing new
keywords and once you choose keywords
you're interested in bidding on you're
gonna actually do a forecast to see
exactly how much you can expect to spend
how many clinics how many oppressions
you can expect to get and if you have
conversion setup how many conversions
you can expect to receive so that's all
part of Google's keyword Planet's buing
forecast as well as choosing keywords so
there are so many different tools and
features within Google Ads we need a
whole whole segment just on this
so really I'm just gonna highlight some
of the more important tools and features
so I mentioned the keyword planner I
mentioned the campaign's keywords and
ads reports another thing I would look
at in Google Ads again we mention this
as one of our key to finding why would
we use it bullet point and that's
because of devices so we mentioned
devices why would we use Google ads
reporting tool because we want to look
at devices and we want to be able to see
what devices are driving traffic from
what campaign and then the cool thing
about Google ads is right in Google ads
platform you can go ahead and do a bit
adjustment so if I increase my bid
adjustment for example in mobile phones
then my particular ad in this particular
campaign is going to show more than on
computer so I can always decrease it for
example do a bit adjustment on a
computer and that means I'm gonna show
my ads less so I can go ahead and do bid
adjustments based on device that's the
cool thing of working right in Google
ads platform is you can make adjustments
right here in the platform based on
devices well you also have locations too
so we mentioned that is one of the
reasons why we want to use some of these
tools and if I see a particular location
I'm money interests in advertising well
I can always select it and I can always
just pause it or remove it so or I can
change the bid adjustment on a location
as well so I can make a lot of different
changes right in the Google ads platform
for those seasons and search advertising
paid search advertising especially on
Google ads you can always use Google ads
editor all you need to do is just do a
search for Google ads editor you can
download it so basically what Google ads
editor is it's a it's a tool it's the
software that you work your kit with
your campaigns on locally so you're
making changes to your campaigns on your
computer and basically when you're done
making changes you can always upload
them to Google ads too
the account on Google ads in the cloud
so to speak so that's the whole idea
behind Google ads editor it's a great
tool for you to use if you want to make
household changes really quick
for example I'm looking at an account
with a bunch of campaigns so now if I
click on one of those campaigns I can
see the ad groups here okay so for
example I just wanted to turn off all
these ad groups so I can just highlight
them all and just click status and able
to paused and I can revert back if I
want to okay so you can make household
changes so here I could see at the
campaign the a group level if I choose
an ad group then I could see some
keywords and again I can make changes at
nauseam here I can copy I can paste I
can delete okay so I can make a lot of
changes really quick right in Google Ads
editor and that's the whole point of
editor is to go ahead and work locally
while somebody else is working locally
on the same account you could both be
working simultaneously and being more
efficient on getting things done in the
campaign now if you are working with
somebody else on the campaign you want
to make sure that you get recent changes
so if I say get recent changes to all
campaigns what Google editors going to
do is contact Google ads in the cloud
and download all those changes so here I
can see the changes being download and
editor from Google ads and when it's
done it's gonna highlight all the
changes that have been made and so once
I'm done reviewing those changes I can
go ahead and click done and now I know I
have the recent latest changes in editor
so now I can go ahead and continue to
make some changes and when I'm done
making changes I can go ahead and post
them so that's the beauty of Google ads
editor Bing has a version Facebook has a
version it allows you to again go at the
keyword level the ad group level okay
you can look at ads itself and make
changes to the ads okay you can do a lot
of different things right and editor in
fact you could do pretty much most of
what you can do in Google ads you can do
in Google ads editor and so that's
Google ads that are to me I would
recommend it
if your experience with Google Ads
gannets software you have to download it
you're gonna use it on your computer as
software when you make changes all you
need to do is post those changes or get
recent changes that have been made on
Google ads and so that's Google editor
ads editor in summary now let's go back
into Google ads and talk about display
advertising because display is a
different network but the platform's
still the same and some of the same
tools are available from the search
Network as well as for the Display
Network writing Google ads so if I want
to take a look at a campaign and AD
group on the Display Network I can just
click on the NAG group and I can look at
the ads that are running for that
particular group on the Display Network
so here the difference being on the
Display Network is you can use image ads
on the search Network you can only use
text ads so here I can look at image ads
and I can see how they're performing in
fact you could even go a step further
and use responsive display ads so Google
has responsive display ads meaning it's
going to respond to what's performing
best okay and so now I can see clicks
impressions click-through rate etc right
on on my ads and extensions report in
Google ads platform now this happens to
be retargeting campaign so if we click
on audiences we'll be able to see what
audiences we're targeting here okay so
when this report loads when you run
retargeting campaigns you're targeting a
specific audience and so we want to be
able to see okay of the audiences we
have set up what audience is performing
best okay so here I can see a breakout
by audience again I can see the same
metrics I could see on the search side I
could see clinic's impressions click the
rate more importantly I want to be able
to measure conversions okay so that's
the whole idea when you're in these
platforms and you're paying for ads is
you want to be able to measure
against conversions and you can also
measure against cost per conversion
conversion rate okay so those are some
key metrics to measure up against
whether its audience keyword ad whatever
the dimension is so here on the Display
Network we can get a sense of
demographics
okay so unlike the search Network the
Display Network allows us to see
demographic data and so now I could see
an age breakout or an age range breakout
that Google provides us and I can see
again based on that age range breakout
which age range has the most clicks
impressions etc including conversions
so you also have the opportunity on the
Display Network to add keywords you have
the opportunity topics and you have the
opportunity to see placements or run
placements so here if I click on where
ads have shown I can actually see where
my ads have shown up for this display
campaign and Google Ads allows you the
ability to go ahead and you can exclude
it from the a group exclude a specific
placement from a campaign so you could
take action on a specific placement and
I could see the type of placement
whether it's a mobile app whether it's a
site I can go ahead and see exactly
where that placement was so that's the
placements report you have demographics
you have audiences you have keywords you
have all these different reports
available to you on the Google ads
platform so Before we jump over to
social media paid search advertising I
just want to remind you we do have you
know a nice tutorial on Google ads okay
so take a look at the Google ads
tutorial we have setup on YouTube okay
if you search for Google ads tutorial
2019 this is a good tutorial on
everything related to Google ads so
check out this video because in today's
webinar we're just mentioning tools
across the board and if you are
advertising on Google
ads as most people do then you can see
just how powerful it is and all the
different features that are available so
take a look at the video it's a nice
complementary video to this one this
digital marketing tools and this will
give you a nice and deeper insight into
everything that's available on Google
ads and if you have any tools or
features on Google ads whether it's the
search Network or whether that's the
Display Network then feel free to
comment below this video happy to hear
your comments about what tools and
reports and features you specifically
use in Google Ads
so let's move into Facebook ads manager
and show you how the platform looks when
you're running ads on Facebook so we can
look at all the different tools and
reports available here so here we can
see if we're in the Facebook Ads manager
we could see our campaigns we could see
your ad sets and we can see our ads so
just like on Google ads you have left
side navigation so we can drill down so
if we want to see ad sets for example we
could just click on ads sets that are
showing up in this particular account
and here we can see we have two ads sets
that are live so if I click on one of
these ad sets I'll be able to see an
actual ad that's running here and so for
the actual ad that's running I can then
see the results of that ad and how it's
performing for example you know how many
clicks it's received what the reach is
what the impressions are so impressions
similar to Google ads how many people
are actually looking at the app and then
I can see the cost per click here at one
dollar as an example and so now I can go
in and I can go ahead and look at the ad
performance and go ahead and change out
that ad if it's not performing to my
expectation so if I click on more tools
and then creatives I can just simply
click on creatives and then I can
actually see the create is I actually
have run
for that campaign I selected so now I
can see all the creatives that are
running and I can see the results of
those creatives so Facebook Ads manager
also has reaped different reporting so
if I click on the reports pulldown menu
you can see here I could see some
standard reports by add at set age and
gender and then I can see all reports
here listed out by placement by
placement and device time of day country
cetera so if we just look at age and
gender we'll be able to get a break out
age and gender here so you can see by
campaign I'm looking at all campaigns
here and I'm looking at just age and
gender I can certainly deselect one of
these and I can look at a specific time
range so now I can see who's looking at
my ad specifically so here I could see
35 to 40 for female I can see the reach
impressions and how often they're
actually seeing my ad now this is key
for Facebook because if somebody's seen
your ad a lot they're probably gonna
tune out to it so that's what's makes
the frequency metrics so important on
Facebook because then we can go ahead
and you know turn off that particular
age and gender if we needed to and we
can see how much we spent so this just
gives you some idea of the type of
reporting that's available in facebook
ads manager now the great thing about
facebook reporting and ads manager is
you know I can group or ungroup my
dimensions if I needed to I could change
the view and arrange columns I can get
rid of columns just as you would in
Google as reporting very similar stature
here so I have a lot of flexibility here
on how I review the reports you know you
got different metrics that you can pick
and choose as well okay and you've got
lots of different flexibility when
you're looking at the reports on how
your campaigns are performing now here I
can pick and choose I can choose
campaign ad set ads objective again I
can choose different demographics so
a lot of options available to me in
terms of how I want to you know view the
performance of my campaign view the
performance of my ad set or my ad now
remember if you're in facebook you can
always go in and edit the campaign you
can edit the ad set remember in the ad
set that's where a lot of your decisions
are going to be made including how you
want to drive the traffic okay what your
budget is okay you can basically choose
your audience here so you're going to be
able to choose what type of campaign is
going to be and based on the campaign
you're going to go ahead and choose the
kind of audience you want to focus in on
you're going to be able to choose the
location the age range the gender so all
of this is going to be set up in the ad
set or the campaign for the ad if you go
ahead and edit a tad remember you can do
a/b testing as well so you have a lot of
different options and features available
to you right in ads manager when you're
managing your paid search campaigns on
Facebook so if you want some more
information about all the different
features and tools and Facebook Ads
manager check out the Facebook ads
tutorial 2019 webinar that we did
earlier this year in addition you can
also look at another one that we did on
facebook called Facebook advertising
tips and strategies so that should give
you some sense of everything related to
Facebook ads and how to take advantage
of the Facebook Ads manager platform so
if there's anything on social that we
may missed or that you use feel free to
add a comment below the video we'd love
to hear your feedback okay let's talk
about some affiliate marketing tools
let's turn our attention affiliate
marketing a lot of affiliate marketing
platforms out there the number one
probably is Commission Junction also
known as CJ they're an affiliate
platform they having a freemium model
meaning you can have a free trial but
basically gonna have to move on and pay
for the platform
likewise for house offers you have
volume you really when it comes to
affiliate marking a lot of platforms out
there
click Inc a when so a lot of these are
brokers per se
and when I say broker is like for
example with CJ you as a merchant or you
as a publisher can get in touch with a
merchant you as a merchant can get in
touch with a publisher meaning CJ helps
bridge the gap between you finding
somebody to build your network with okay
so that's what really affiliate
marketing is and you need really need a
platform to kind of put it all together
and means a lot a lot of affiliate
marketing platforms we're actually gonna
take a look at CJ and go through some of
the features in the platform here
shortly but let's just take a look at
why we need these affiliate marketing
tools well these affiliate marketing
tools identify you know affiliates in
floors employees other advocates you
want to partner with so again you'd be
on the merchant side you could be
actually selling a product and you're
gonna want somebody to help you sell
that product somebody with a website who
is an influencer who drives a lot of
traffic to their own site who you know
does Sall reputable brand etc so you
need somebody to help you introduce you
to these sites ok so CJ and some of
these other marketing platforms
affiliate marketing platforms do that
okay so these tools are there to do the
introductions they're brokering the
relationship so the other benefit here
is you can contract with affiliates and
track the traffic and conversions well
what do I mean by that well if you do
you CJ comm by no means am I only
endorsing that platform there are plenty
of others out there but whatever
platform you use you're going to want to
be able to set up terms and conditions
with that particular fill yet so you
could set up with terms and conditions
for say 10% off all sales as an example
okay well you're getting me a platform
that will help you broker
that contract okay contract terms or
program terms furthermore you need a
platform to help you track hey is this
affiliate helping me drive traffic or is
this affiliate driving traffic to my
products and this is affiliate a helping
me sell so you these platforms help you
do just that okay so you can gain the
high website rankings with the help of
your affiliate meaning that hey your
affiliate can be promoting your product
and if they're promoting your product
you have a chance to show up via paid
search organic search off other websites
so social so you have a lot of benefits
to working with affiliate marketing in
itself and the tools available will help
you gain website rankings as one example
we want to be able to track certain
metrics okay so in affiliate marketing
you have earnings per click
EPC as an example most platforms measure
EPC from a seven day period to a three
month period okay you can also figure
out what the actual cost per click is
just like you do on say Google search
you can actually measure that in
affiliate okay you want to eliminate
fraudulent clicks impressions in
conversions so any affiliate platform
worth its weight is going to help you
understand you know how many prussians
and clicks and conversions you're
getting and help you manage that terms
of fraudulent clicks or hey if you're
getting a lot of impressions and no
clicks that's a problem too
so these platforms are really built on
helping you manage your relationship
with the affiliate by offering up all
sorts of reports and tools you know the
other big benefit here to affiliate
marketing tool is hey we can influence
our customers throughout their buying
journey so we could set up different
promotions based on hey did somebody go
to the website did somebody see our
product does somebody click on a product
that somebody go into the shopping cart
with our product did somebody purchase
our product so there's all sorts of
steps and the funnel so to speak and hey
you can work with an affiliate a
publisher to influence your
Smurfs two out that purchasing funnel
throughout that journey so let's go
ahead and log in here so when you log in
like any other digital marketing tool
any other platform you're gonna have
your own settings and whatnot so really
the whole idea behind any affiliate
marketing tool is really there to manage
your publishers who do you want as a
publisher who do you want selling your
product
you obviously want somebody who's
relevant somebody who's going to be able
to sell the product so many ways a
targeted audience it's similar to yours
okay so we go in - CJ comm we're gonna
log in and here you can see a
publisher's link so we're gonna click on
that publishers link and remember when
you sign up publishers you have to have
program terms and so if we click on
publishers program terms we're gonna be
able to see all the different program
terms available so here we can see the
different program turns we have setup
for certain publishers so we just click
on that we'll be able to see that's the
default program term so remember you
could set up your own program term for
any publisher so as a best practice if
you have publishers who are actually
performing well who are selling your
products maybe you want to offer them a
little bit more on the Commission side
maybe you want to sweeten the deal maybe
you know these guys these publishers get
better program terms versus say other
publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you can
see what the terms are the action and
the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products CJ is the
broker they're the ones who are going to
initiate the payment based on the
program terms so be careful in the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately CJ has templates CJ
has some default program terms that you
can use and offer up to different
publishers so Bay
on the program terms that's how you
publishers are gonna get paid and so
here you can have as many different
program terms as you want there's no
limit here you want to be able to align
and reward program terms again based on
performance and so here we can see what
publishers are under what program terms
so again if your publisher is performing
well sweeten the deal offer them a
better program terms and so you can
align publishers with different program
terms and so that's the whole idea
behind program terms is you want to be
able to align publishers with that so
when you sign up a publisher they're
gonna get a line with the program term
meaning what are they gonna get paid for
selling your product now if we want to
manage by status instead of my program
terms we could see all the different
organizations we have in our network
these are our publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know who's selling
who's not selling and so we can look at
all our publishers by program terms or
by status okay so basically you can see
here the term status whether it's active
or not earnings basically what they've
sold over the last basically seven days
or three months so you could look at
basically how your publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in CJ com so when you're
looking at reports in CJ comm or really
any other affiliate program you might
see the acronym EPC this stands for
earnings per click actually it's a
little misleading it's actually earnings
per 100 clicks so basically CJ
calculates you know how much a publisher
is actually making per click you know
just like paid search we're paying
Google X amount per click it's the same
thing here we can't for these publishers
can't make any money if they don't
generate clicks so that's why you have
an
PC model or metric so to speak so you
can measure earnings per click CJ does
it over a seven day period in over a
three month period so you could sort
based on seven day or three month to see
who is earning the most per click in
terms of publishers now you can select
under publishers groups now you can
group your publishers okay so if you
have say a group of publishers and a
specific region like the United States
or India or if you're just focused on
the United States and say if publishers
in different states like Texas
California Missouri Arkansas
Wow you can group those publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see Canada and so we have our
publishers grouped into a group called
Canada why because they're based in
Canada makes sense so you want to be
able to organize your publishers because
the whole idea behind affiliate
marketing CJ is you want to be able to
get the best publishers available for
your network and so as you get more
publishers for your network you'll be
able to basically start grouping them
where it makes sense now the example I
gave you is by geography you could do by
geography or you could do by publisher
status meaning my best performing
publishers go into a group if they're in
a group then they get aligned with a
certain program term so you could group
your publishers any way you want by
status meaning they're selling more
these are our best performing publishers
or by region or you know by promotion I
mean how you group your publishers is
totally up to you however take advantage
of the option to create publisher groups
because the whole idea again I'm gonna
repeat it is you want to get publishers
and you want to start building your base
of publishers because the more
publishers you have the more chance you
are to sell your product
remember if nobody clicks on your
product then nobody's going to buy your
product so
if you have publishers who are promoting
your product for you then you have a
good opportunity to sell it so the more
publishers you have on board the better
the opportunity so now once you have
publishers you can start grouping these
publishers accordingly to whatever makes
sense is a business decision just know
the options available in CJ to group
publishers let's turn our attention to
social media marketing tools social
media always a great topic to talk about
so we're gonna finish up all our digital
marketing tools with social media we
talked about SEO paid competition
affiliate email you know web analytics
it's just appropriate to finish up with
social media because social media has so
many tools available so many okay the
first one I can think about it here is
HootSuite HootSuite is a great social
media marketing tool to use okay it's a
freemium okay you can set up a free
trial here you basically a base account
and then you can use HootSuite to do a
lot of things
anything from setting up landing pages
to actually publishing content to
listening HootSuite to me is one of the
most powerful social media marketing
tools available you got buffer buffer is
a paid version but you can actually set
up a low cost or free account actually
i'm buffer and then move to a paid
account
okay you got tweet decks been around a
long time that is actually free and I
would recommend tweet deck and we're
gonna take a look at that here in a
couple minutes okay and then you got
sprout social sprout social is another
social marketing platform summer to
HootSuite do a lot of reporting a lot of
publishing you can a lot of listening
and so we're gonna take a look at sprout
shows for the day as well before we do
that let's go over why these tools are
important to us from a social media
perspective you're pumping out a lot of
content so you need to be able to
smartly efficiently
you know schedule and manage your post
okay so you're not just working likely
with just one platform like Facebook
you're probably on a number of different
platforms depending on your business
pending on your bandwidth depending on
what you're selling your products etc
your audience obviously has a lot to do
with it you know it could be Instagram
Pinterest you want to be able to
consolidate all that and manage it in
one place and that's what social media
marketing tools do they allow you to
manage everything in one place so if you
could manage everything in place then
these social media marketing platforms
need to be able to make it easy for you
to add and manage different accounts
okay so a lot of them have the ability
for you to add you know not just one
Twitter account but multiple Twitter
accounts and not just one social media
platform but multiple social media
platforms and a good social media
marketing tool worth its weight will
help you monitor the results so monitor
social media posts that help drive leads
and sales in other words you're gonna
have a lot of different metrics
associated with each social media
marketing platform okay which one is
actually doing its job okay so you want
to be able to easily manage these
platforms applications and websites very
efficiently okay so instead of having to
log into each platform is log into one
place get a sense of what's been posted
what the engagement is did they purchase
etc and what you want to do is be able
to individually customize every social
media post across different platforms so
it just makes it a lot easier to do that
in these social media marketing tools
okay you don't want to send out a
blanket message across different
platforms you want to be able to go
ahead and customize a post depending on
what that post is depending on what the
product is what time of day what target
market what target audience so
customization is a lot easier using
these social media marketing tools you
want to be able to engage with brand
advocates so listening is a good thing
with social media marketing tools using
the listening functionality so you can
actually see who is a brand advocate
who's not a brand advocate who's an
influencer who's not an influencer and
then of course you want to analyze the
behavior of your audience
optimize individual post on real-time
data so if for example you post
something using one of these social
media marketing platforms and you see it
go viral then you want to be able to
react to that in real time so you're
gonna be able to see that in real time
on these social media marketing tools
these platforms like sprout social and
HootSuite and then you're going to be
able to react to that behavior and then
of course monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key we always
want to monitor conversions based on our
KPIs our business goals so there are
also a few important digital marking
tools that can help you in different
ways okay so without further ado let's
jump in and take a look at what's
available in terms of social media
marketing so just a quick reminder if
you are running ads on Facebook or
you're posting on Facebook as an example
or any platform in general that platform
is going to have its own metrics if you
will so for example Facebook has
something called Facebook insights
you'll be able to actually see you know
what's been posted based on you know the
last seven days in this example how many
page views you're getting engagement
recent posts so just to let you know yes
you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
Facebook Ads hey you can go right into
Facebook Ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that you
can measure all that in one place so if
we log in to sprout social I can set up
these accounts right into sprout social
so I don't have to log it in Twitter
individually or Facebook individually I
can link them up all within sprout
social and then I can go to reports just
like I can with Facebook Insights and
then once I'm in Facebook excuse me once
I'm in sprout social reporting then I
can go ahead just like I can in Facebook
Insights except it's all right here for
me I can jump into you know Facebook
and dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so I don't have
to log into Facebook directly I can see
you know the impressions the engagement
the clicks over a period of time I could
see my audience growth I can see my
publishing behavior how often my
publishing I can see the top post
individual I can see impressions by day
you know a lot of this same material
same information is already in Facebook
Insights so if it's available on
Facebook Insights you know you're
definitely going to have it available in
a tool like sprout social so you want to
be able to just efficiently log in and
jump from one platform to the other so
here you know I can go to Instagram you
know and look at Instagram data or I can
look at Twitter information so you want
to be able to efficiently jump from one
platform to the other using in this
example sprout social now as I mentioned
as part of one of the benefits of a
social media tool is that you could
publish content you want to be able to
publish content because you want to be
able to organize and schedule
accordingly you don't want to be
submitting and publishing content right
after one another okay you want to be
able to spread it efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is click compose select a profile write
whatever we need to do you could
schedule it for tomorrow at a specific
time and there you go
voila schedule so this is on Twitter
okay so you know we could choose another
platform here it's just that easy to
schedule so you want to be able to
schedule accordingly because again when
you schedule something then you want to
be looking at the behavior of it so it's
just as simple as going from publishing
to report it and then based on once
something got published you can see the
reaction of it and react to it
so another thing here that I like about
it's about social HootSuite a lot of
these other platforms do it really well
you got listening tools so you can
listen in on conversations that are
being have for example mail delivery you
know we do man deliver and Twitter
we'll be able to see what's been tweeted
about mail deliveries you know if that's
the business we're in we can refine our
search and choose a specific location or
radius to hone in if we're local okay so
this is sprout socials example of
listening here let's take a look at
another example I'm in later comm so
later very similar sprout social in that
it does a lot of the same things you can
actually schedule content on a
particular platform and one thing I like
about later here you can actually see it
visually you can see calendar and what's
been scheduled so I can see today I have
scheduled something scheduled at 1:15
local time and again I have five
profiles set up for this account so I
can pick and choose the profile that I
want to publish to so it just makes it
that much easier and I can visually see
it and that's important so here I can
click on media library so the one thing
about later comm is that you know you
have a library of images that
potentially you can reuse so if I click
on this image here okay I can get a
sense of when it was used and I can view
it on a calendar I can out label for it
so that's another benefit to later is
that they have this media library here
they have conversations so I can
actually connect to a platform and
listen in on conversations that are
being had similar to the listening tool
in sprout social and they have analytics
so you can actually see right in later
comm how your particular social media
platform is performing so I can see it
here over seven days I can see the
number of followers have increased I can
see the growth rate I can see the number
of impressions that I've received okay
so I want to be able to see how my
particular platforms performing over a
period of time so I can look at reach to
law profile views website clicks okay so
I can get a lot of good insights here
right in the analytics platform later
you can look at specific post
performance so if we post is something I
could see basically how many likes have
received how many comments you
oppressions the reach and then if I want
to do I can click on details and get
more specific information on it
engagement rate ok discovery actions
comments saves etc so later calm goes
into some nice detail about post
performance they even have date on
hashtags so if you use an hash tag you
can actually see how many times the hash
tags been used or saved how many
impressions it's received ok so they
really go into some nice detail here
about how your post and how your
accounts are performing and here's a
tool I really like I've been using for a
long time and that's tweet deck so what
tweet deck does is connect with your
Twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
Twitter account looks in terms of your
feet here I can see this is my feed here
ok I can see some notifications I can
see specific messages then on this
column I can see activity ok so I can
add different columns here if I wanted
to and basically by adding columns you
can see I can look for what's trending
as an example so I'm gonna add in a
column that says trending and so now I
can go in and see ok these are all the
different things that are trending on
Twitter so you can actually add a column
and pay attention to something really
specific okay so for example search ok
so right now I have men's health but I
could type in let's just say world cup
okay so I can see the you got the
Cricket World Cup you got you know the
soccer football World Cup going on so
you know we could pick a particular
topic to follow if we wanted to so again
here I'm following men's health so I can
now see you know everything that's been
posted on men's health now if I click on
for example one of these hashtags here
that's trending I can actually see who's
tagging or using that hashtag Friday
feeling in their tweets and so the whole
idea behind you know tweet deck it
serves up a interesting
overview so to speak not only your
account but you know a specific topic or
what's trending or you know other things
that are being said so if you really
want to pay attention to your brand or
something really specific like you know
your competitors or a specific product
then you can just do a search on that
and so that's the great thing about
TweetDeck it allows you to kind of just
look and listen in on everything going
on in Twitter now we do have a good
video out here on YouTube how to start
social media marketing so if you haven't
had a chance to look at it take a look
it goes over some of these tools that we
cover today like sprout social later
calm you know Facebook Insights so it
does cover in more detail some of what
we covered on these social media
marketing tools so take a look at how to
start social media marketing so we
covered a lot of different marketing
tools digital marketing tools everything
from SEO to email to social the paid to
affiliate competitor but there's also a
few other digital marketing tools that
you can use in different ways like video
SEO for example so vid IQ you know we
want to use vid IQ to get a good sense
of how particular videos performing so
here if we go into YouTube you can see
vid IQ is a browser extension or browser
a plug-in if you will so I can go and
take a look at a specific specific video
and see how many hours it's been watched
how many views minutes watched
subscribers etc you know the great thing
here I can look at the entire entire
account so I can get good insights into
my video or my entire account here just
by adding in the vid IQ extension into
my Chrome browser so vid IQ actually
does give you some really really good
insights into not only your account but
the video and so recommend vid IQ
because it's good for video SEO ok
there's also tools related to content
optimization so you know if you're doing
SEO and you have a lot of content in
your site well
you know I we want to be able to use a
tool maybe a third-party tool to give
some objective reasoning as to what more
we can be doing so you got tools like
SEO site checkup or site analyzer these
are paid tools but you know if you're
really heavily invested in SEO then they
may pay dividends for you you want to be
able to make sure your content is fully
optimized to the fullest according to
you know Google's algorithms and so you
may be you know one invest in that
third-party tool so these are good tools
to use for content optimization you know
this is a other key reddit but you know
this keyword planner in Google there's
also word stream there's a lot of
different keyword tools out there so you
may not have a Google Ads platform and
so if you don't have Google ads then you
may not be able to gain access to
Google's keyword planner so having a
third party keyword tool will pay
dividends as well because those
dividends pay off in the form of not
only pay-per-click
but also SEO and if you're heavily
invested in content a heavily invested
in social then you may want to take a
look at the keyword tool keyword it and
it's primarily used for reddit we talked
about page load time so we looked at
that in Google Analytics we know that it
heavily impacts SEO so there are other
tools available
you got a third-party tool here that's
free SolarWinds Pingdom you actually
have PageSpeed insights by Google so
these are free tools that you could take
advantage of and determining how you can
improve your page load time my favorite
topic conversion rate optimisation so
you got a couple in here crazy egg and
czar get okay so I'm gonna show you
another tool called hot jar so here if
you log in to watch our calm you can set
up an account it's actually free and
with the free account you can have hot
jar measure the heat map not only the
heat map with the click mapping the
scrolling of a particular page and so
here you can see we're looking at a
particular page here so hot
allows me to you know see on that page
where people are clicking I can also see
where people are moving I can also see
you know the scrolling of a particular
page okay so you can see here on the
page I can see people are moving over
here to the right
that's where they're clicking Hmong
mostly if I switch over to move mode
then I can see on that particular page
where people are actually moving their
mouths and then I have my scroll
analysis so I can see you know how far
down people actually scroll on the page
and so again with a paid account you can
measure up to ten thousand pages with
the free version you can measure up to
two thousand pages and so two thousand
pages allows you to get some insight as
to what people are clicking on or where
they're moving or how they're scrolling
on a particular page and so I definitely
recommend a hot jar they also do
funneling those who do forms polls lots
of other tools available in hot jars so
hot jar calm is a tool I would recommend
as well so one final tool and I'd be
remiss if I didn't mention it and that's
Google optimized so Google optimized is
a Google platform that allows you to a
be test and so a be testing means that
you have an original page and you're
changing one element on that page to see
which one performs better and so with
Google optimized it's just very easy to
set up to run and the whole point of
Google optimized and a/b testing is to
improve website performance so here you
can see I have an account set up an
optimized you can see we're running one
test here and we're just testing one
element versus the original so we move
photos to the top of the page the
original didn't have the photos to the
top of the page and so we can go into
reporting here Google optimize does all
the heavy lifting and so here you can
see we can look at bounces or we can
look at you know basically a measure the
test up against the metric that's
important to our business and again the
whole point is to improve website
performance and so definitely take a
look at Google optimize
we'll have another webinar in the future
on the topic but you know it's me Google
optimizes free you can run up to five
tests okay and if you can run up to five
different tests and that means you have
the ability to really improve website
performance okay so Google optimize is a
tool that I would recommend okay so we
could probably go on for a few more
hours on all the different various types
of digital marketing tools that are out
there on the Internet
we covered a lot of them from paid to
email to social a lot of more free a lot
of them are paid versions in between you
got freemium so go out there experiment
have fun play around if you have a tool
we didn't cover that you feel our
audience should know about then go ahead
and put them in the comments section
under this video thanks for hanging in
there covered a lot of good information
today I want to thank you paying
attention if you have any more
information please visit us at simply
learn com thank you hi there if you like
this video subscribe to the simply learn
youtube channel and click here to watch
similar videos de nerd up and get
certified click here